[Música]
ah
lamento decirles que no tengo respuestas
sino que tengo preguntas
qué tanto elegimos
que tanto estamos condicionados
qué tanto nos gusta las mujeres que
somos
hay muchas mujeres de distintas edades
clases sociales
cuerpos con pelo sin pelo
ahora hay algo para varias cosas que nos
hacen
igual es absolutamente a todas
primero que somos mujeres más allá de la
elección de género que tengamos de lo
que fuera somos mujeres
y por otro lado
que todos somos hijas y nietas de una
mujer
y estas mujeres
te dará la primera versión del mundo
da nos abrimos la puerta al mundo
a cómo somos a los valores a los
pensamientos y nosotras la vivimos como
verdad no como una interpretación no
sólo sabemos si nuestra mamá mira de
izquierda de derecha o del centro para
nosotros era verdad
hace 42 años que estoy en esta
investigación de que sea una mujer
primero de manera personal y hace más de
10 años que lo hago de manera
profesional soy psicóloga mi profesión
es una de las pocas profesiones en las
cuales uno conoce a tanta gente tan
íntimamente
y a partir de esta investigación he
llegado algunas conclusiones
entre esas conclusiones a que llegado
una es que si una mujer depende de la
época no es lo mismo que era ser una
mujer para los años 50 que para la
actualidad en los años 50 por ejemplo el
cuerpo de una mujer mira y queda linda
una linda mujer totalmente distinta a lo
que es en la actualidad hoy por suerte
estoy de moda
otra de las conclusiones a las que he
llegado que la mujer que está de moda es
ir alcanzable poco realista
exigente al mango y no se están formando
otra hollywood no existe y cuando
hollywood no existe no es hollywood no
existe no existe no solamente que no
existe en principio no existe castillo y
además lo financiamos nosotros y la vida
mucho más larga que una película es como
cuando me casé no no no se cansa entra
si uno cree que tenía la película la
película sigue
sigue sigue sigue
y la definición de felicidad
hollywoodense que tenemos creo que la
que nos está haciendo infelices
todo hemos presentado que lo que estamos
hablando todas las charlas desde que
pensar decir comunicar es absolutamente
natural el humano tiene una condición
que damos por sentada y no tomamos
conciencia de lo excepcional que es
pensamos en nosotros mismos el humano
tiene el lenguaje ya través del lenguaje
no admitimos conocimientos pensamientos
creencias tradiciones hábitos
un pájaro no se pregunta qué es ser un
pájaro es un pájaro tiene toda su
genética para sobrevivir cuando gaviota
se lo pregunto
y es mucho más rápido evolucionar
palabras que evolucionar de genes
hoy estamos evolucionando de manera
consciente
y eso es realmente increíble a mayor
conocimiento mayor conciencia menores
miedos los primitivos le tenía miedo al
rayo porque no lo entendían
y así como en su momento se habló de
inconsciente colectivo hoy estamos en el
peso de tener un consciente colectivo
ahora podríamos separar la condición
humana en dos partes primero la
biológica que no voy a profundizar ser
mujer es una condición biológica tenemos
la capacidad reproductiva
independientemente si querramos son o
reproducirnos
pero tengo todo en mi genética
mirada periférica el hombre por ejemplo
tiene mirada en foco porque necesito
tener todo lo que me prepara para eso es
la parte hembras y se quieren de la
especie humana y por otro lado tenemos
un condicionante que tiene la eficacia
de la biología
pero es inconsciente que se social
estamos condicionados de manera social
y estos condicionamientos los tomamos y
los vivimos como verdades
somos sujetos sujetados a lo social a un
paradigma y a una cultura hoy está muy
de moda la palabra paradigma y pensamos
que es algo lejano que está fuera
nuestro y el paradigma está dentro
nuestro somos lo que decimos somos lo
que pensamos y yo represento en mi decir
a la época en la que estoy
entonces la búsqueda me empezó a
preguntar bueno de dónde viene la
construcción que hoy tengo de mojada
y ahí indefectiblemente tuve que ir a
mis ancestros a las mujeres que escucha
hablar a mi abuela y mi madre mis
abuelas y madres
primero
la juzgue dije qué horror y si ellos
como mejor me convertí en esto
después de juzgar las las empecé a
comprender las empieza a aceptar
las empezó a perdonar y las de llamada
y allí recién pude escucharlas y
entender que ellas también fueron
mujeres de época y lo que me dijeron
eran lo que creían que tenía que ser
y empecé
a recordar los decides de mi abuela que
decía mi abuela a la hora de tratar de
educarme como una buena mujer pórtate
bien para comportarte como una señorita
ángeles no te subas a los árboles
y ahí
cuál es el modelo de mujer de mi abuela
primero el modelo era el momento
d
certeza nuestros abuelos si hacemos una
dialéctica de estos ancestros nuestros
abuelos en el momento del modelo mi
abuela no se preguntaba si era que si se
casaba si viajaba si tenía hijos o si no
los tenía en un momento de certeza del
paradigma ser mujer es igual a ser madre
la sexualidad estaba supeditada
reproducción por eso existía en lo que
me es abuela mi abuela semanas kokott
las otras las las cual quieras
esas gozaban del goce
después de eso cuando hoy estamos en
otro momento de ese de esa cuestión
el apego eran mujeres que pasaban de
depender de sus padres a despertar de un
hombre
si la madera sobre una pregunta seguirá
y en ese mundo se vivía ahora para que
existe una transformación para que
existe una evaluación que llega en un
conflicto cuál es el conflicto de la
época de mi abuela
que había mujeres que querían más allá
de ser madres no cuestionaban todavía si
se iban a ser madres era además
otra de las cuestiones es que la señora
quiso ser mirada y deseada
como las y las quisieron ser
amadas y respetadas como las señoras tal
es así que kennedy tenían estas dos
mujeres a marilyn y hay aquí
ahora el tema cuando una salió al ámbito
público
y en este contexto nace mi madre
mi madre nace en un momento de
revolución del paradigma
en un momento donde lo que se cuestiona
es yo no quiero ser como mi madre
todavía no sé si se estaba construyendo
un modelo primero se estaba poniendo el
modelo
yo quiero ser distinta mujer paso está
en oposición a la maternidad mujer
versus madre
más falta y susanita para los que son
jóvenes y lo conocen ahora más falta no
era alguien en sí mismo es no quiero ser
como susanita
ahora en toda la elíptica para que haya
un tercer momento que es el de la tesis
tiene que hay una antítesis ahora
momento de antítesis cuestión el modelo
es como si mi abuelo es todo en la ruta
y la creación de mi vieja creó la
banquina pero el modelo de referencia
seguía siendo la ruta
se llama de casa pasa a ser poco y hoy
que soy ama de casa
ojalá tres años más en el feminismo no
me habrían contaminado
se dieron cuenta también que ser más
falda y susanita se independiente
independiente porque la generación de mi
madre fue la conquista de la
independencia ahora en este mundo
independencia se llama dinero
y ser más fácil de susanita es
dificilísimo fue una generación que
aprendió el mundo de lo masculino así
como esta generación está aprendiendo el
mundo de lo femenino
la creación de mi madre aprendió el
mundo de los masculinos en el mundo real
de lo que creía que se tenía que tener
que existía
un mundo que los hombres conoce hace
mucho más tiempo
qué es un mundo difícil
y además la generación y mi madre
apareció la moda ser mujer fue mucho más
caro entonces un buen proveedor fue
mucho más difícil
y en este
pero en todo esto
en todo esto en toda esta conflictiva y
en todo este momento maravilloso y de
apertura una generación tiene que tener
un pensamiento para que la siguiente lo
pueda empezar a construir
y estamos nosotros
esta generación en donde podemos elegir
donde sea no se trata de la ruta a la
banquina se trata de decir cualquier
camino el problema que queremos elegir
todos y hay caminos que no tienen
retorno hay dos cosas que no tienen
retorno la muerte y la maternidad esa
nunca lo había precisado uno dice que no
puede volver una vez que lo tiene tiene
ver cómo tiene que ver cómo se las
ingenia
ahora podéis no poder poder no querer
tener hijos y es válido y es lindo y es
una vida posible
por eso existe el pánico el pánico es la
encrucijada que hay en un punto donde
uno tiene la posibilidad tomar muchos
caminos claro pero que lo que nos pasa
ahora antes son un solo par de
zapatillas para todos los deportes hoy
vas a comprar de que vas a hacer de
running de no sé qué entonces te llevas
mucho tiempo elegido
y elegir implicar responsabilidad
estamos en el primer grado del ejercicio
de la libertad las mujeres
y ser libres
no es fácil
porque tiene costos
porque pasamos de esas líneas hacer
minas soy mi niña le pedí a un padre una
mina le pedí a un hombre las mujeres no
tenemos que auto gestionar lo que
queremos
porque estamos todos en este mundo
difícil remándola y nuestra generación
tenemos el desafío de la integración de
la tesis
donde entre dos términos la dependencia
de mi abuela la independencia a mi madre
nosotros podemos tener la autonomía del
ejido donde esos términos que estaban en
la oposición no tenemos la posibilidad
de tener la de la elección de transitar
quitar el conflicto entre el apego y
desapego disponibilidad
hombre mujer humanos o
mujer ver su madre no mujer y madre ser
femeninas
porque en definitiva las mujeres
al igual que los hombres dentro de las
sociedades tenemos un rol y en esta
época tenemos la posibilidad de hacer de
este rol algo que cambie el mundo
porque no si de eso se trata
tengo dos hijos varones lo cual también
se me complicó porque quiere decir a
decir que un día en mi cocina cocina mi
casa y estaban dando vueltas a las diez
de la noche que soy yo que es la hora de
la bruja es mejor que estén dormidos
porque se encuentra con un ser
despreciable
[Música]
y estaban ahí digo
yo robaron tome conciencia que era la
responsable de
crear la historia de la que mis hijos
iban hablar
yo era la que estaba
haciendo los momentos que ellos iban a
recordar
y después sí qué horror
empezó un gran trabajo que fue cambiar
en vez de seguir mirando
cómo usar mejores a los varones
me empezó a preguntar cómo podía hacer
para hacer una mejor versión de mí misma
un trabajo se hace
cinco años que estoy trabajando en eso y
entender que tanto las mujeres como los
varones tenemos muchas facetas
que tenemos que ir trabajando y
conociendo yo
el personaje que soy
soy
mi esencia un granito de arena
mujer común a todos a todas
i
de época en estas circunstancias
nosotros somos personas de épocas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]